brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system if
someone told you deliver us the moon you
would pretty much have to do it such a
commanding title so evocative and here
on the show floor at South by Southwest
it's certainly grabbing attention I'm
Chris waters here on the front lines
talking to Chris developer of deliver us
the moon Chris what it what do you mean
when you tell me to deliver you the moon
because I'm ready to do it well actually
the situation in the game is pretty much
well it's going down right now all of
Earth's rad natural resources are pretty
much depleted and you're the last row
gasps not that says you know what I'm
going to go to the moon I'm going to
solve this problem by myself I'm going
to be exploring all these abandoned
bases on the moon because all these
astronauts were being sent by the world
wide space agency to the moon in order
to conduct research there but because of
circumstances they had to come back and
this is actually taking place exactly on
the years after the Apollo landing and
while we're just get out that it looks
like we have no resources left we're
gonna go extinct and I don't I don't
know how you feel about it but I don't
like that idea doesn't sound ok to me
exactly so yeah you know the player
takes up the role of this rogue
astronaut that doesn't like the idea
either and it's going to go for it okay
so you've got a moon full of these
derelict spaces you're trying to figure
it all out well you know what what
people were doing there what they of get
them back on track I for the player
experience you're you're sort of
exploring how open is the exploration
between these different bases well it's
actually going to be very open as
possible we want to call this actually
an open world game but it's actually
more of a semi open world game because
you're going to be managing your
resources like oxygen and this limit
sorta you're you're yeah your reach of
being able to travel around the moon for
example because of the game is going to
be released episodically constantly
we're going to be building up new new
faces and new zones on the moon to make
it bigger and have more places to go and
explore so constantly the game becomes
bigger and they're like new places to
explore so it becomes bigger and bigger
it's up to you where you want to go now
watching people play the demo here it's
a very solitary experience
you're sort of this loan astronaut like
you were saying but I there's also this
tension you were saying of sort of
resource management here it's only so
much oxygen you're not running around
the moon breathing air so how did what
do you what kind of atmosphere you
trying to create with deliver us the
moon yeah it needs to be this very
serious sort of dramatic experience out
there because it's very very solitary as
you said before he's going to have one
friend down there there's actually that
little robot and he's handing in his
hands that's ace he's gonna be like your
little guide and together you'll be
having his experience or not completely
alone but there's like constantly a
clock ticking out there you have oxygen
to manage you have energy yes power you
have maybe something is trying to get
you out there that you don't know before
you know so who knows what's going on on
the moon that has been like desolate
because of all this research has been
going on for all these years and now for
the last few years nobody was there so
who knows what has happened in meantime
you know very cool I gotta say ace
bearing a strong resemblance to his his
ancestor space cube right from portal to
the guy who's just super thrilled to be
in space it's nice to see that space
cube found someone to reproduce with oh
yeah he definitely made a great job
because he's super cute haha all right
now so deliver us the moon when it sort
of what platforms you guys even to
release when are you aiming to release
and also I see you're going for VR as
well very good question well we're
definitely going to release the game on
PC through steam is going to come out on
the Xbox one we're trying to get the
game out on the ps4 as well but no
guarantees for now on that we're looking
into also having mac and linux support
for the game and we're definitely
looking into making this game we are
compatible all right Chris deliver us
the moon very cool title cool looking
game thanks for chatting with us here at
South by Southwest
you